[Music]
there are a number of categories of
tools each for each stage of the
software development lifecycle phases
some tools straddles there is phases
some are very specific to individual
phases so let's look at the first stage
which is requirements analysis and it's
all about communication within the team
and talking across different roles so we
need to be able to allow developers
managers customers business analysts or
to talk the same language and think
about that various tools that we want to
use so fairly obviously word processors
and spreadsheets are those spreadsheets
are often very much abused and can cause
a lot of problems share calendars so we
know when meetings are sprint management
tools although a lot of sprint
management tools are very low-tech
wiki's are incredibly useful for storing
information which is readily accessible
we need UML diagram tools to describe
our applications and we need issue and
task management tools to manage the
workflow we have the concept of artifact
creation an artifact is simply a
by-product or result of some operation
on some kind of code so very important
to source control systems they manage
the versioning of our code and make sure
that we building the right thing from
the right versions of the software
we've got continuous integration tools
very important for detecting problems
early so that they can be fixed and so
they don't delay other developers work
we have build tools which assemble the
components of our software from source
code through the various artifacts to
the production executables we also need
to gather documentation information and
there are tools that do that
the most complex stage of any software
development is the code development
stage and there are many tools that are
needed at this stage as a variety of
different editors we need different
databases different types of databases
different tools for building the
software we need tools for code review
there's also him very important Co
quality tools which can assess the
quality of the code and identify common
problems very quickly
we have there is things like the rest
API design and that's very difficult
thing to do develop an API for
communicating across a network using the
REST API is is very very difficult to
coordinate user interfaces are also
incredibly difficult to describe and get
to work well we also need to be out a
map code to databases we need unit
testing and mocking frameworks to make
sure that our code is fully custody then
very important integrated development
environments they save a lot of time
developers effectively have an operating
system for which they can develop code
without having to go outside of it and
then of course we've got the in
compilers and interpreters which tend to
just work behind the scenes turning our
code from source code into executable
code
testing is vitally important we start
off with unit testing and mocking
frameworks for doing test-driven
development
we've got scripting for writing more
advanced tests such as integration tests
we've got test harnesses which test full
systems and partial systems and we've
got user interface playback tools for
testing web interfaces we've also got
packaging tools we have repositories
where software is stored which we can
fetch and integrate with our system at
any time build tools appear here again
we've got container management tools we
should grow increasingly important
people like the use of containers where
you have one application per unit of
deployments which could communicate with
each other and then we've got the
deployment descriptor generation tools
which is very also very important
because deployment a scriptures which
describe how software interacts with
containers are very difficult to write
then we got release management tools
which are also very important change
management systems we don't make change
into production unless it's been fully
documented and approved we need for
systems to approve releases we need to
have important role map mechanisms if we
deploy an arrow Gnaeus system into
production we need to get back to the
previous version as quickly as possible
we need to automate the process of
release we also need to be able to
schedule tasks so that we can run
various components of the system at the
right time in the right sequence and the
important enterprise integration tools
which has allow us to deploy and change
applications dynamically automatically
very important configuration and
monitoring tools
for structure configuration and
management we don't want to do it
manually once it automate it we have the
concept of infrastructure as code
basically scripting which controls the
infrastructure request tracing tools
find out exactly what happens when a
request is made is it been executed and
put into production performance
monitoring is vitally important make
sure our systems are doing what they're
supposed to be do in a timely fashion
also log file analysis tools many many
systems produce a lot of log files the
output is very very verbose we need to
look for the interesting things which
are usually things going wrong which are
very small parts of logging they will
need to be out of report issues as soon
as we could detect them and grab the
processing mechanism in place to deal
with them hey once become an expert in
cloud computing then subscribe the
simpler Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn it up and get
certified in cloud computing click here